if i was gonna remake the wizard of oz
i'd remake it with robin williams and
that's it
just let him do the whole thing by
himself so here we go who dares bother
the all and powerful wizard of oz
oh my god incredibly wonderful please
but who the heck does your decorating
silence whoa tacos for lunch you're just
gonna
see the little people like the other
crowd father whoa lovely fantasy island
mansion grammy willy wonka part two ooh
not that funny but fun to say amber
dance everybody come on madonna madonna
con but where's the ice cream i know but
i'm turning on the inside it was amazing
and wonderful because i met up with the
guy who's made it a straw i said hey man
whoa hey man stroll that's a joke right
there
let's go to la that's where it is and i
land on hollywood boulevard it's junkies
and pimps and [ __ ] oh my
yes it's like dorothy on acid this is
what it's about
and there's bud like the wizard of oz
going don't look behind that curtain
don't come into this club now
hi
trick or trend
[Laughter]
that's a damn good question
trick treat quite the conundrum
having said that my young costumed
friends
as fade would have it i too have a
question
which one of your little kids can guess
what i've buried under my house
hey kids
my cat walked in with a mouse really
do you have a cat
no but they they scream
when they bring you something they have
a kind of scream of triumph right
so while i was talking to her the cat
screamed and she said what's that
and it was a cat it was my cat
and
don
i'm a nice guy
all right king facal of saudi arabia so
so glad you could count
hope you find a parking place for your
camera
anyway may i say something here harness
can i say this from the bottom of my
heart
you gotta be the ugliest king i've ever
seen in my life
your face was a building and be
condemned
i make fun of people paul rodriguez a
great mexican kid i swear to god my wife
and i were in mexico city for two weeks
never saw the city she kept saying i
think it's a salad
i said no it's a goddamn tomatoes it's a
tomatoes
you know what it was it was the waiter
you want a burrito
how about an enchilada you want an
enchilada
and then the guy tossed the salad for
crying out loud
look at the black brother laughing you
son of a gun the one with the blow gun
anyway uh
i make fun of the black people without
you we'd have no
hey uh olympics
what are you looking at but ed hey why
don't you make like a tree and get out
of here
you know that that that is a great line
and that is so great you know the stuff
you guys are doing with the 50s and
everything no i had jackets like this
can you believe that i'm the old guy
pick a guy out once a year and wine them
and dine them for a year and provide
them with vestal
you know they provide them with vestal
persons and
at the end of the year they take him to
the top of a pyramid shake his hand and
throw him down the stairs
and i i'm gonna go into hiding in
december
the other night uh maybe a week ago
jeff the robot here did uh a morgan
freeman voice all night did he yeah i
don't i don't know how does it sound
like morgan well i think maybe if he
could if you're talking about it doing
it a little bit now you could maybe
judge it do you mind no i don't i'm not
let's see
would you like to hear my morgan freeman
voice
[Applause]
see when i open my mouth it makes
everything sound smart
that's outstanding yeah it's outstanding
it's very very good first time i've ever
heard myself from the outside yeah
there there's through the wormhole
keyhole right there
i'll freak you out that would that would
yeah what do you want to say to yourself
yeah what would you i don't know think
of something nice
all right
let's talk about craig ferguson no
go ahead i dare you
damn you look good
listen here's the thing steve
his name i swear to god i listen i do
every movie steve i'm everywhere
listen it's me dwayne johnson and meryl
streep swear to god that's all you get
yeah i mean it's just that
[Laughter]
so
uh dwyane wade is another good friend of
mine wayne tried to mess up my life
dwayne he didn't no no dwayne dwayne
tried to make me buy a boat i don't even
have a house i said hey man
i told him
i told him that i said hey i don't have
a house i don't think this is a good
purchase he's like you should just get
it right i was like no i would but the
weight of my bank account is set up
it's a checking in the savings right but
all the money is in my savings right i
can't i can't transfer it out my savings
that fast it's three business days three
minutes
i don't want to be on the phone that
long
kevin how are you nice to see you oh
shut up dave
they like it
i like it i worked on something just for
this moment
okay i had to write it down
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
oh thank you
but i get a cappuccino
oh dave you're a big man yeah
i'll give you a stick of gum you can
show me how to chew it
[Applause]
it was during one of those episodes of
drinking in london that i turned down
dog day
i actually turned it down i said
i said i don't want to go into a bank or
rob a bank and do all that stuff i was
talking like this
and i actually turned it down good to
have you on the show nice uh nice to see
you how are things going pretty good
dave i mean i mean there's a lot of
places you could be but i mean
anytime you're at a place like this
things start to get you know you want to
be on a in a funny place and this is one
of those funny places and for another
place and it's not as funny but i mean
why am i that way i
what i wanted to be was in a funny place
and boom i mean i'm having it right now
good thank you you know he just has that
ability pat whatever it is
to win football games if you look at him
he's not the biggest guy he's not the
strongest guy sometimes he doesn't even
throw a spiral on the football but it's
just that he knows how to play the game
he knows how to win the game and i think
the big thing is that the players really
believe in him and it's not only the
offensive players it even goes to the
defensive players in fact dan hampton
was saying this week he said how can we
lose
i know
i know you love me tonight but will you
respect me in the morning
hey how how about this how about this
weather where
we're having out here in california in
the wild
a beep room went off in the audience
see if you can call my writers on that
damn thing
i know you know you're not doing well
when a guy calls for the paramedics
during the monologue
they got that scene where they meet for
the first time and pacino's sitting
there with de niro he's bringing [ __ ]
down to him he's like you sir her a bad
guy
i am the police
it's my job to stop guys like you
murderers rapists killers that's what i
do
there may come a time when i pass cross
i'm gonna have to take you down i won't
like it but i'll do it keeps me hot on
my toes where i gotta be
de niro comes back
you know there's a flip side to that
coin
good friend of mine jimmy once told me
never get attached to anything that you
cannot walk out on in 15 seconds flat if
you spot the heat coming around the
corner and i also like guys like you
that like guys like me because you keep
me hot on my toes but i gotta pick
and you're right i pads they may cross
i'm gonna have to take you down i won't
like it but i will not hesitate
great scene now hold up picture the same
scene with stallone and schwarzenegger
you ain't gonna be able to understand
[ __ ]
stallone is doing but you know
you know there's a flip side to decline
i must have to take it down i won't like
it without doing it well
even deaf people like what do you think
[Applause]
what do you think
[Applause]
he has to train blindfolded to
disassemble the weapons in orders he can
never look down what he does and the way
he draws the weapons and when he shoots
he cannot blink and you know this is how
he used to walk and this is how he has
to turn like a machine that he said to
me he says you're really into that
character says why don't you play the
character and i said oh i hope i didn't
open my mouth